this morning member states have also
reached a general approach on the
decision on the employment guidelines
the guidelines support national
employment policies and are such
important tools to achieve our Europe
2020 goals in particular for the target
to reach 75 percent employment my
mistakes have agreed to monitor progress
and provide sound analysis as input for
the guidelines and country specific
recommendations in this regard today we
adopted counsel conclusions about the
annual growth survey and also adopted
the annual joint employment report
during this morning's discussion we
touched on labor mobility I confirmed
that the Commission will tomorrow
present a proposal for revision of the
rules of posting on posting of workers
aiming to ensure fair conditions for
workers and a level playing field for
companies when preparing this proposal I
have listened carefully to the views of
all Member States and social partners I
believe this is a balanced proposal and
for Europe to be successful in the
future and equally important to remain
credible for European citizens we need
to reinforce the social dimension of the
European Union particularly in the euro
area we looked back one year from on
from the launch of the new start of the
social dialogue to take stock so what
has been done in you during one year
since a new start of the social dialogue
and since then the Commission has
delivered on each of the priorities of
the new start and I would like to
highlight four main changes a more
substantial involvement of the social
partners in European semester at
national level new forms of consulting
year social partners on policy
initiatives behind treaty-based
obligations a stronger emphasis on
capacity building of national social
partners and clarification of the
relations between social partner
agreements and better regulation agenda
we have a very bad data on basic skills
in Europe for instance twenty percent of
European
slack basic skills that means reading or
counting and forty percent of them have
hardly any or no digital skills far too
many young people drop out of school
early that's why this case agenda will
not only seek to equip people for
today's labor market but also to enable
them to acquire a broad set of life
skills that will allow people to adapt
to the evolving nature of work
throughout their careers